hey everyone this is shruti from simply
learn welcome to this video on the
business analyst full course in this
full course video we will learn all
about the currently trending topic which
is business analytics
for all the aspiring business analysts
out there this video will help you learn
more about the job role of a business
analyst
so without further ado let's get started
we'll begin this full course video by
understanding the need for a business
analyst in an organization
we will have a close look at the duties
carried out by a business analyst
through an interesting story
after this we will have an in-depth
understanding of the various skills
required to become a business analyst
following which we will look at the
business analysis knowledge areas after
this we will look into a hands-on demo
on business analysis with excel
we will then conclude this video by
drawing a brief comparison between the
two most popular job roles today
business analyst and data analyst
for this training with me i have
avijjeet and we will take you through
the various topics in business analytics
all of this in under two hours
so let's start with an interesting story
on business analytics but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simplylearn
we will understand the importance of
business analyst with a sort and
interesting story
so meet rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
rob's cafe was hugely popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly
coronavirus
due to kovite 19 like other eateries rob
was forced to shut down his cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts
he remembered that business analysts are
professionals who enable a change in an
organization he felt like a business
analyst could help him sort out his
current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst
he hired ted the business analyst to
help him with his ongoing business
problems
rob entrusted ted with reopening the
business
the first step ted took was to have a
discussion with rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take
on discussion with rob ted learned that
the business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that rob also wanted ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic
ted studied the case and he came up with
a few suggestions that he thought was
fit for rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for rob's
cafe
this way ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario
next ted suggested that rob has work
from home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
professionals in the middle of a busy
day
ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from rob's cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price cuts in the current situation
finally ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by rob for the app ted began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the i.t team
that became the intermediary between the
iit team and rob he provided suggestions
to the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well ted
held regular meetings to gaze the
progress and also kept robb in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project
attending regular catch-ups helped rob
gain an insight into the progress and
gave his feedback from time to time
ted made sure that the entire case was
well documented by doing so he could
always refer to the documents in the
future with similar cases as well
ted
made presentations that showed rob the
business growth after implementing the
changes and ted always supported his
presentations with data
rob was very impressed with ted's
business approach
such an approach not only helped rob
reopen his business amidst the cove at
19 but also helped him get 80 percent of
his customer base back ted successfully
brought about a positive change in rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how ted the business analyst
helped rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst
well yes depending on the business
domain and the situation the roles and
responsibilities may vary let's start
off and have a look at a day in the life
of a business analyst through a small
story so meet angela who is working as a
business analyst in an application
development firm
her firm builds applications for clients
depending on their requirements our next
character is rob he is a budding
entrepreneur with a vision of setting up
his own e-commerce app he plans on
selling several electronic gadgets like
phones laptops cameras etc on his app
so what is rob's first step well he
approaches angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app angela and rob start talking
business and angela promises to help rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running rob is happy about
it and increased to cooperate with
angela regarding all the business
requirements from his end angela as we
know is the business analyst she starts
planning rob's project and without any
delay she embarks on this project's
journey
she has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about angela's approach that helps her
deliver rob's projects smoothly and
without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these roles
better with respect to angela's and drop
story first and foremost angela
understands rob's business objectives
problems and requirements
without understanding this do you think
angela will be able to proceed no hence
a business analyst like angela
understands the problems related to
rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is best suited for an e-commerce app
focusing on electronic gadgets in the
next step angela gathers all the
necessary requirements
here she understands rob's requirements
and makes sure that they are on the same
page regarding the project and its goals
both of them together arrive at a
stipulator deadline for the project
completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
ways to login cost of the products and
style to name a few
once angela has an in-depth
understanding of rob's project and
gathers all the necessary requirements
she starts allocating resources by
keeping in mind the budget of the
project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
bas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the app's layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in the next step angela
collects feedback of the prototype
version of the app from the users
she notes down if the prototype is fine
or if it requires more work pas validate
if the project is running fine with the
help of use acceptance testing they
verify if the solution being worked on
is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use expectations
bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba
in order to gauge the performance of the
app and get valuable insights from it
angela builds reports using various data
visualization tools like tableau power
bi and quick view reports can be general
reports such as detailed reports or it
can be dashboard reports such as
visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to crop up amidst
this entire process
hence angela conducts regular meetings
with the development team and rob to
solve problems quickly
having these meetings will help rob
understand the status of the project and
it will also help the teams proceed in
the right path throughout this project
phase angela makes sure to maintain
transparency on completion of the
project angela documents and presents
the project findings to rob
generally business analysts present the
project outcomes to the stakeholders and
clients along with maintenance reports
angela notes on all the project
learnings and details in a concise
manner this will help her take better
decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project
now that she has completed all her
duties and responsibilities with respect
to rob's project she is ready to deliver
the final e-commerce application to rob
for use rob is rest assured that the
application developed by angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted
angela's streamlined approach made it
easier for the project to be delivered
within the stipulated time period rob is
happy and i'm sure he will come back to
angela's firm for projects in the future
so those responsibilities that we saw
angela carry out are ideally the roles
and responsibilities for any business
analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project
you're working on if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for bridging the gap
between i.t and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements deliver
data-driven solutions and generate
reports to executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense
so you should have a clear understanding
of the roles and responsibilities of a
business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what all
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while bas identify the needs define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client face
to face can do wonders and even help in
solving problems quickly they engage
with business leaders and users to
understand how data driven changes to
products services software and hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally bas write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a
project business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills
the skills for a business analyst are
not only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations and the
motive behind the problem so let's have
a look at the top skills to become a
successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts will resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improve revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increasing marketing budget according to
the revenue
business analysts would have the natural
curiosity and determination to continue
learning and figuring out how things fit
together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill a business
analyst would have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by thomas
elva edition which says
five percent of the people think
10 percent of the people think they
think and the other 85 percent would
rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think
a business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts require good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those
that should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual
you have to speak several different
languages while conveying the same
message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point they use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
this would be capable of facilitating
meetings
business analysts use verbal and written
communication to convey ideas concepts
facts and opinions to a variety of
stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients business
leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
representatives industry leaders and so
forth
business analysts negotiate at every
turn during the course of a project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project
as details emerge negotiation skills are
used by all parties involved to
determine which requests become
requirements and which requirements have
higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills
business analysts also perform cost
benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this balancing act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business
thus it is important for every business
analyst to think from all aspects before
presenting the decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well
business analysts should have a knack to
think out of the box and find a solution
to problems
majorly a business analyst follows five
major steps while making a decision
these steps are define the problem
find and define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and tests
and finally implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for designing the
solution the business analyst still
remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached half way
through the skills i would like to ask
all our viewers to please subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is
idea about programming languages
business analysts would have a good
hands-on programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of r and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
problems by writing efficient codes
both r and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics some of
these libraries are numpy pandas deep
flyer tita ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like sas
and spss using these programming
languages such as python r and sas you
can analyze and visualize large datasets
as well as create machine learning
models for making future business
predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be general reports such as detail report
grouped report crosstab report column
report query report data entry report
etc or it can be dashboard reports such
as visualize report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analyst to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and sql
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as microsoft sql server oracle
database mysql database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with sql
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
microsoft excel is the ninth skill in
our list
excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with
data business analysts use excel to
perform various calculations budget
analysis and data analysis to derive
meaningful insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using excel
to generate dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use excel to
create revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analyst can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems
while business analysts are generally
not responsible for making decisions
regarding project solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assess decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution
with that we have covered our top skills
for a business analyst
if you have any questions related to the
skills that we covered then please put
it in the chat section our team will
help you solve your queries
now
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career in business
analytics and help you become a business
analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and
on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analyst so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst masters
program
now
this program is endorsed education
provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this master's program
so there is introduction to business
analysis
certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum
there's business analytics with excel
we'll also get training in sql this
tableau training
and you will also get to work on
business analyst caption projects
if i scroll down
now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so
there's microsoft excel zera tableau
power bi
postgresql
then this plan box target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if i scroll further
is the entire course content we have
these are the different courses
that you will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to this
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have post graduate program in
business analysis
now this is in
partnership with podu university and
endorsed education provider is iipa
if i scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course
you get
purdue post graduate program
certification alumni association
membership
master classes from purdue faculties
enrollment in simply learns job assist
there's 170 plus hours of blended
learning 11 plus hands-on projects
custom projects in three
domains if i scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
purdue certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get
the certificate received by
international institute of business
analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to simply learn job assist
program so you will get i am jobs pro
membership for six months
resume assistance and career monitoring
you'll also have interview preparation
and career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so
you will learn about an introduction to
business analysis certified business
analysis professional
there's a island scrum
business analytics with excel tableau
training business analyst capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
purdue university business analysis
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there is agilent scrum foundation
if i scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so
this business analysis
there's alicitation and collaboration
requirement analysis planning and
monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing does data visualization
statistical analysis using excel
sql database
there's requirement lifecycle management
and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have microsoft
excel zera fogburst
plan box that's rally power bi pro
square sql
that's version one target process and
others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industrially
related projects that you will get to
work on once you enroll to this course
so the first project is canteen ordering
system for unilever
we also have library management system
for stanford university
there's whatsapp pay and you can see the
description of these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
hospital management system for myoclinic
there are course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
purdue university
if we scroll further there's the
learner's profile and how the industry
trend has been for business analysts
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst
now here is a quick roadmap that depicts
what a fresher needs to possess to
become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field
then
knowledge of sql and relational database
is very important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst
up next we have the roadmap that depicts
what an experienced professional needs
to possess to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write sql
queries
an experienced professional should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by international
institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial
let's now learn the business analysis
knowledge areas
first up
we have business analysis planning and
monitoring now this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize and
coordinate business analysis efforts
it involves planning business analysis
approach stakeholder engagement business
analysis governance as well as
information management
then we have illustration and
collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements lifecycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
tasks that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their lifecycle
it covers the creation changes
prioritization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
define the future state assess risk and
define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures
assess solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects
the first methodology we are going to
talk about is the agile
methodology agile is an incremental and
iterative approach to project management
and software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles
teams can manage a project by breaking
it up into several stages and involving
constant collaboration with stakeholders
along with continuous improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals budget time duration for
completing the project and resource
needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints
after each sprint
we get a shippable product and that
product is reviewed by the client or the
stakeholder the suggestions are
incorporated in the next sprint
here you can see we have sprint 1 sprint
2 and sprint 3 and all of them have the
6 steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process
now let's discuss this scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process frameworks for agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members scrum significantly
increases productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals
okay so the concepts and practices in
scrum can be divided into three
categories
first we have three roles
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria
they are responsible for privatizing the
product backlog and deciding the release
date and the content a product owner is
the one who is responsible for the
return on investment or roi of the
product a scrum master is a servant who
encourages and demands self-organization
from the development team they enable
close cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
agreements the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
the sprint backlog includes only what
needs to be completed during the current
sprint
it often has greater detail and more
complete user stories than the rest of
the product backlog once created no one
can add to the sprint backlog except the
development team the product increment
is the version of the product that will
be delivered at the end of each sprint
while the sprint backlog outlines what
must be completed within a sprint the
product increment details the outcome of
all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer
the final category we have is sprint
ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total
in sprint planning the team
meets and decides what they need to
complete in the coming sprint
sprint review is a type of meeting in
which the team demonstrates what they
shipped in the sprint
in the sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better
daily scrum is a stand-up meeting or a
very short like 15 to 20 minutes meeting
for the team to make sure that they are
all on the same page
now
let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst
according to pay scale the average
annual salary of a business analyst in
the united states is
eight thousand nine hundred and seventy
three dollars while in india a business
analyst can earn nearly six lakh rupees
per annum now talking about the
companies hiring for business analysts
we have the indian e-commerce payment
system and financial technology company
paytm american mnc cognigent and british
dutch multinational oil and gas company
shell
we also have cisco the search engine
giant google and dell
finally in our list of companies we have
arnstein young global limited american
multinational computer technology
corporation oracle and british
multinational investment bank and
financial services company barclays
with that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts
we have the widely used spreadsheet
application microsoft excel
web-based kanban style list making
application trello relational database
management systems such as mysql
microsoft sql server and postgresql
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product zera and
tableau software for data visualization
okay so let's look at our demo on
business analyst training
often times business analysts work on
structured data using excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and pivot
charts to summarize and analyze data
find trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the united states and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are
nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns
you can see this is a sales data set and
the first column is of order date then
we have the shipment date we have the
shipment mode next we have the customer
name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name there's only united states then we
have the different cities from the u.s
we have the state names
and if i go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the sub
categories next we have the product name
then we have our sales value
now you can assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the years
in different regions of the united
states
so for that
i'll click on any cell inside this data
set
go to the insert tab
and here i have the option to create a
pivot table
i'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data
and here i'll choose new worksheet that
is the place where i want to place this
pivot table
and let's click on
ok so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2
and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table fields so since i want to
know
the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so i'll click on
remove field
i don't want this field so i have my
ears first
and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for
all the years in different regions so
i'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
if you want you can go ahead and rename
this row labels and column labels
now
with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will help you analyze your data
better
so what you can do is
go to the insert tab and here
under recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here and click on
ok
there you go
how easily excel has created a pivot
chart for us based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region
so the sales had declined from 2014
to 2015
and then it gradually started increasing
from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was steady from 2014
till 2015
then it increased in 2016 and after 2016
it became constant
similarly you can analyze the south
region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well
let's go to our sheet one where we have
our data set
let me click on any cell i'll go to
insert
and i'll choose pivot table
here
let it be new worksheet i'll click on ok
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field
and now
i'll choose
category
under rows
so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what i can do is
i'll choose segment under columns
you can see i have my pivot table ready
so here you have
the furniture office supplies and
technology as the categories of products
and on the top you can see consumer
corporate home office has the different
segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so i'll
go to recommended charts
and
let's say this time i want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on ok
if i close this
and i bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments
now if you want you can edit this chart
as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right
similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons
okay
all right
now
let's suppose you want to know which
segment made the highest and the lowest
profits
so for that you can create a pivot table
as well
so i'll click on any cell
go to the insert tab
and choose pivot table i click on ok
all right
now say
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so i'll first choose profit on to values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows
so we have our pivot table ready
now here if you want to know which
segment made the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do
sort smallest to largest which is in
ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment made the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart
let's do that
i'll go to insert
and here under recommended charts
i'll select
pi
and let's click on ok
there you go
we have a nice pie chart ready
now the gray color pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table while the blue
segment which is actually home office
made the lowest amount of profit
now let's remove this field from here
i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is
you can edit the
chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say
profit
by
segment
and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
i'll say sales
by
segment
and
category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
i'll click on the chat title and here
i'll
write sales by
year
and
region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know
the total units that were sold for each
sub category of products and the
shipment mode
so here we have the shipment mode
and you want to know the total units
that were sold which is basically
this column the quantity column
for each sub categories of product you
can see we have different sub categories
like bookcases this chairs labels this
tables furnacings art phones binders etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll go to the insert tab
click on pivot table
and click on ok
all right
now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
i'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
subcategory
under rows
so i have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart i'll go to the
insert tab
click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
legends which show the
shipment mode let's click on ok
i close this now
first let's remove these fields i'll
right click and i'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can
add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see i'll select
yeah this one
you can see
it has given dots for each endpoints
which means
this is my first sub category as you can
see the second sub category the third
subcategory which is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read
and understand the chart well
okay now
let's add a chart title
i'll write
quantity
sold
by
subcategory
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10
okay
now you
also have the
feature to create
different kinds of maps in excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that made the
highest and the lowest sales in the
united states so you can create a field
map for that
so first of all let's go to our data
sheet
i'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
and click on ok
alright
so since we want the
state and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows
and then i'll choose the state field
under rows
now let's
drag sales under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if i sort this
data you can easily know
that california state made the highest
amount of sales
now if i scroll down
below you can see
north dakota made the lowest amount of
sales
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
tab
and
under grand totals you can select the
first option you can see the grand total
has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so i'll click on
united states
i'll right click
and
i'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
i'll click on
show item labels in tabular format
and i'll also click on repeat item
labels you can see
it will populate united states for all
the rows if i click on ok you can see
the united states have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here
i'll close this
go to the design tab
under subtotals
i'll choose do not show subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and
i'll actually paste it somewhere here
now with this data
i can go to the insert tab
and choose maps
let's select field map
there you go
you see
we have a nice field map of the united
states
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue
let's say california made the highest
amount of sales you can also validate it
from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart title here
i'll
give a chart title
as
sales by
states
and let's remove this legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if i choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the california state
is shaded in dark which means it made
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well i'll just remove these two
all right
now
similarly you can also create a field
map
to see the profits by each state so you
can analyze which states made the
highest amount of profit and the state
that made the lowest amount of profit so
let's do that
i'll go to my data sheet
i'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on ok
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows
and then i'll choose state under rows
next
let's drag
the profit column under values
so i have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design tab and remove
the subtotals
i'll select do not show subtotals if i
scroll down
okay i have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under grand totals
we'll remove it
okay
now let's just populate the united
states which is the country name for all
the rows
i'll right click on united states go to
field settings
click on layout and print i'll choose
select item labels in tabular form and
select repeat item labels
let's click on ok
so i have my
country name populated throughout
let's
select the pivot table
i'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
i'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits
for each of the states
let's first delete this
and edit our chart title
which is
profit
by
states
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
i'll make it as white
and let's say
we'll
choose the color
as
say this one
okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
legend here
and just delete it
all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our
different pivot tables and pivot charts
let's build the final dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing i need to do is i'll go
to the view tab and i'll remove the grid
lines
all right
now let's go to the insert tab
and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right
let's pull this a little down
and this to little right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's
give the text as
sales
dashboard
and we'll
give a white color to the text
and i'll select my font
you can select any font you want
so i'll go with
let's say
britannic bold
okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to
30
and we'll center align it all right
now
the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet
so i'll first copy my
pivot chart
and i'll paste it in sheet 8 let's paste
it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well i'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the
size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11
okay and let's
drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the
pie chart
and let me paste it here let's reduce
the size of this pie chart
okay
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different sub categories of product i'll
copy it and let me paste it
somewhere here
i'll close this
and we need to reduce the size so that
we can fit in our
other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right
now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this
and
let's paste it here
i'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our dashboard ready you can
see the different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts
so i'll
click on this
first chart which is our line chart i'll
go to the insert tab here you can see
under filters we have slicers and
timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
i'll choose my order date column
let me click on ok
all right
let's drag this a bit here on to the
right
and i'll show you how you can use this
let's
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and i'll go to report connections
here i'll select
all my pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard i click on ok
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
i'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
now let's add
a region slicer i'll click on ok
and let's take it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slicers are nothing but
filters which have
advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment so i'll go to slicer
i'll choose segment here and click on ok
so you can see i have my segment slicer
here let me just reduce the size
and let's drag it
here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline
suppose i want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015.
so the way to do is
you can select one of the years so i'll
click on 2014
and now i'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if i
go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15.
similarly
if you mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say i want to
have 2016 year included as well i can
just drag it to the right
you can see the charts will change
i'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to
see the sales and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and
let's say you want to know the sales and
profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
we just cancel this
now
you might be wondering when we selected
the different regions only the pie chart
changed
but the rest of the charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click
and go to report connections
here i'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well i
click on ok
all right
now let me just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
sales and the profits
and the quantities sold for let's say
south region
if i select this you can see it shows
only for the south region
let's see you also want to know for the
central region
now we have selected both central and
south you can see the variations in the
graph
we cancel this
similarly we have our another slicer
which is the segment
i'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on ok
i'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say i want
to know the seals the unit sold and the
profit for
home office segment so i'll only select
home office
you can see the variations here
now the slices actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to
know for the corporate segment you can
select cooperate or if you want to
select for multiple segments you can do
that as well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email ids in the comments section
our team will send you the files over
email we'll compare the two most popular
job roles in the field of information
technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst
business analyst is a professional who
bridges the gap between the it and the
business teams in an organization they
use data analytics and modern
technologies to assess processes and
deliver data-driven solutions
they understand and solve a business
problem and validate business
requirements
a business analyst generates reports for
executives and stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered they also
assist in the integration and testing of
new solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with a rapid increase in data generation
today the term data analyst has found
its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues
they thoroughly understand the
requirements from the clients and assign
the right resources
bas communicate and work closely with
the development team to design the
solution for a problem they ensure that
the development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations bas assess the functional
and non-functional requirements
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results they present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions
now let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process
data analysts collect data from various
heterogeneous sources they assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
data for analysis they work closely with
different team members like programmers
business analysts and data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis
they use a variety of analytical
statistical and business intelligence
tools to spot trends and patterns in
complex data sets discover hidden
insights and prepare summary reports for
the leadership team they also use
programming languages for data mining
and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba
a business analyst should have a
graduation degree in any relevant field
such as business accounting information
systems human resources or engineering
you can apply for entry level business
analyst positions or with professional
experience
excel is a powerful analytics and
reporting tool for working with data
bas use excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan an
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
base sql to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases
critical thinking skills are important
to understand customers business needs
it allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a lower priority
base should find different ways to
address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project
knowledge of tableau power bi and
qlikview is required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience to solve
complex tasks and perform faster
analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as r and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicate it in front
of the stakeholders and clients
let's now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess
you must have a bachelor's degree in any
relevant field or be a graduate in
statistics economics or science
you're eligible to become a data analyst
being a fresher or as an experienced
professional you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are working
in once again knowledge of excel is
another basic requirement for a data
analyst
data analysts often work with structured
data so they should be proficient in
writing sql queries using data
manipulation and data definition
commands
they should know how to create stored
procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python r
sas and javascript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions
data analysts create data visualizations
using libraries such as matplotlib
c-bond ggplot and plotly
this helps them to perform exploratory
data analysis
knowledge of tableau and power bi is
required to create different business
reports with the help of graphs and
charts
data analysts should have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms to build
sophisticated models and make future
predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
finally data analysts should also
possess good communication and
presentation skills
now let's discuss a salary structure for
both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the united states earns an
average salary of 69 000
while in india you can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the salary of a data analyst according
to pay scale in the us a data analyst
earns an average salary of sixty
thousand seven hundred and ten dollars
per annum and in india you can earn
around four lakhs twenty four thousand
rupees per annum let's now move on and
look at the different companies hiring
for business analyst roles here we have
oracle the search engine giant google
the american mnc cognizant and
e-commerce company amazon in addition to
that we have ernest and young technology
giant ibm dell and cisco hiring business
analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have twitter google the
social media leader facebook and amazon
we also have the american oil company
shell the electric vehicle company tesla
apple and the american credit reporting
agency equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career as a business
analyst and a data analyst
simplylearn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with purdue university the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course are strategy analysis
wireframing
evaluation dashboarding data
visualization agile scrum methodology
scrum artifacts statistical analysis
using excel and sql database
some of the tools covered in this course
are microsoft excel tableau power bi
jira postgresql planbox and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get im jobs
pro membership for 6 months and obtain
35 iiba pd cdus and 25 pmi pdus
you will get 170 plus hours of blended
learning along with capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
purge university and ibm
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using excel data analysis in
python and our data visualization using
tableau and power bi linear and logistic
regression modules clustering using
k-means
supervised learning and others
the tools that you will learn are numpy
pandas scipy scikit-learn excel and
others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get purge your post
graduate program certification industry
recognized ibm certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and master
classes from purdue faculty
you have 180 plus hours of blended
learning 14 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs and capstone projects in
three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
business analyst interview questions
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
we'll go over some beginner intermediate
and advanced level questions to expect
in interviews when you're looking at
business
analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question
dealing with business because in
business they want to make money and we
really want to understand where the
split is on a lot of these things always
ask yourself where is the bottom dollar
on this and what does this mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening
so risk is a potential problem that can
be predicted risk may or may not happen
in the future a proactive response plan
is formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks
so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there is no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company specific
and so when you start looking for work
you start going in for interviews
you should start really asking yourself
what are these companies looking for
that i'm interested in
clearly if you work with ibm you want to
have your tools that are central to ibm
and the ibm setup same thing with google
with you know just across the whole
field
some of the more basic ones
obviously an excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list
but your python your sql you should
really know your sql it's going to come
up in no matter what format you're in
your tableau your xur your balsamic all
these are different platforms there's a
lot more out there but you should be
aware on which platforms your
proficiencies are on and those also that
you might not be proficient on but you
at least know what they do and what
their performance is so you can answer
questions and
a lot of companies will pay for you to
be certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand
any one of these in a little bit more
detail than just knowing the list
what is feasibility study
a feasibility study is a method of
gauging the success rate of proposed
business solution it enables business
analysts to discover new business
opportunities
and uh really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at a for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility uh that is a
very central question that comes up
in most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done
what is business model analysis business
model analysis is a technique that helps
you analyze if a business is financially
economically and socially viable or not
i know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that
so it's a very high-end
job niche where you really need to know
your stuff and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs
we look at requirements requirement is a
targeted solution that is required to
achieve the set business objectives
business requirements are data used for
business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result
business needs include identifying and
comprehending the businesses goals and
articulating its strategic direction
and you can think of needs are what do
we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip pin codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes pin codes of various cities from
the us and india here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing city from
the field list
click on the insert data option and
select state from the field list
really you do need to know your way
around excel no matter what other
packages you're working with
excel is such a base package in business
analysis
so much people are giving that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in india
you can use the sum if function to find
the total revenue generated from india
you can see here equals some f and then
of course b2 to b100 india l2 to l1001
and that will give you
the sum you can also use a filter option
to filter the data only for india and
use subtotal by pressing alt plus equals
nice short hotkey to remember there
create
a highlight table to visualize the
revenue generated from offline and
online cells for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies use tab blue
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use
you drag the region onto columns drag
the cells channel and item type fields
onto rows select the total revenue
column and drag it on to color and label
cards select square as the mark type
drag the total revenue filled onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows place item type column on to
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select asia
so
one of the things about tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop and so you should know your way
around about doing some very simple drag
and drops for doing your query and
summation and below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
differentiate between software
development lifecycle and project life
cycle
so look a little bit more hierarchical
towards the top of the list software
development lifecycle helps with the
development of software products it
consists of a single software across
multiple phases
here phases include requirement
gathering coding operations maintenance
and documentation
where the project life cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business project lifecycle consists
of multiple software in one customer
scenario
phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
analysis
how do you perform risk management in
your project
so again we're dealing with intermediate
not just how to pull tables across we
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced
assessed and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high
risk avoidance whereas risk avoidance is
carried out to avoid the risk from
occurring meanwhile the business impact
here is zero and the cost is fully
eliminated and you can think about a
brick and mortar store
and they have shoplifting
you want to mitigate as you want to
avoid as much shoplifting as you can
but you can only frisk people at the
door and have security so much before
you start losing customers and so when
you mitigate it you're gonna have to pay
for your lost merchandise where you
avoid it you have your security cameras
and people watching to stop
uh people from stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent
badly spent on equipment certifications
there's all kinds of areas where you
want to mitigate and avoid risk
what are project deliverables
project deliverables represent a
collection of measurable services and
goods that are to be delivered to the
end user in the project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model
two of our biggest or most basic models
used today the agile model which is
slowly taking over especially in
software
the agile model is adaptable to
requirement changes and has an
incremental approach
in the agile mile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology
changes and requirements are difficult
to implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
final phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall uh setup
you're not looking for fast changes
you're looking for a very solid
it's going to work no matter what kind
of view this is something that we can
build it doesn't have to make major
changes but it better work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like moscow and swat
moscow analysis it is a prioritization
technique that highlights a requirements
significance question like is it a
must-have or it should have
could the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the swot analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
swot analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats
and you cannot kind of think of it as
like the swat team coming in uh
to you know be worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in moscow really what is um what can we
get out of this you know is this do we
have to have it to succeed is it going
to be useful in the future so you're
looking more for a general value
attached to it list various components
of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives
mission strategies
action plan
what is benchmarking
benchmarking is a process of evaluating
an organization's measures like the
quality of policies programs etc against
the standard criteria
it's so important to have that baseline
of what are you measuring against the
baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before i even jump into this i have a
friend who was working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
uh and he was supposed to meet him at
the in location
when he arrived they had been in a fist
fight while on their private plane the
stakeholders had so much difficulty with
some particular aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
work with anybody but you want to listen
patiently to the stakeholders point of
view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise
comprehend their worries and be
transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
i'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the
ignore somebody who's being difficult
but the rest of it is stay focused stay
focused on what you're trying to
accomplish
be goal driven this is a great time to
be goal driven
not driven by emotion or the problems
that arise or how the person
communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming xp
feature driven development fdd
crystal kanban dynamic systems
development method dsdm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
there is an agile just a ton of
different methodologies so knowing at
least a few of them inside and out and
having a kind of a general idea that the
other ones are out there is important to
at least know what we're talking about
when someone comes up and talks about
agile
describe the gap analysis gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result
gap analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities
and you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into ms
excel
and
remember excel is one of those things
that has been around forever and even
though it's like the bottom barrel of a
lot of uh
analysis that we do
most of our data starts in an excel
spreadsheet
or a comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an excel
spreadsheet
given below is the employee text file it
has information about name agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into excel
go to the data tab click on get data
drop down under from file select text
csv select where the text file is
located in your system and click on
import click on load data imported into
excel
you've been given cells data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is we go ahead and select a cell
in the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table
drag region and item type onto rows drag
total profit onto values
sort the sum of the total profit column
using the cells table find the
percentage contribution of cosmetics to
the total revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values
right click on the revenue value under
show value as select percentage of grand
total right click on a profit value
under show value as choose percentage of
grand total
and you can see here when we do that we
end up with cosmetics made a 14.03
percent contributions to the total
revenue and an 18.94 contribution to the
total profit how do you create a dual
axis chart in tableau
drag the order data onto columns and
convert it into continuous year drag
total revenue onto rows and total profit
to the right corner of the view until
you see the light green rectangle
synchronize the right axis by right
clicking on the profit axis
under the marks card change sum total
revenue to bar and sum total profit to
line and adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data create a view to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an excel file
data in tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column under rows place the total
profit column under color and choose the
desired color palette sort the units
sold axis in descending order
you can see here it produces a very
quick
bug figure shows the fruit sold and the
least and had the least amount of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
middle east and north africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select middle east and north
africa
bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017.
drag the units sold filled on the
columns drag the region and item type
fields on to rows under the cooler card
place a total revenue column drag item
type onto filters and choose clothes
meat and baby food drag the order date
column onto filters and select 2016 in
2017
meat had the highest units sold and made
the maximum profit now with any of these
tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
so that's an important thing to note we
kind of zoomed in on tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package
that's a good thing so at least you know
what we're talking about you've had that
hands-on
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization
we had moscow technique we mentioned
that earlier the requirements are
grouped based on must mandatory should
high priority
could
not necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no
notional 100 to distribute among the
requirements
so the 100 method is pretty similar to
what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
picked their top 10 requirements
this is very popular there's a lot of
help books out there about getting
things done they say write everything
that you want to accomplish
put them on three by five cards and
narrow it down to five
do those five because once you've
conquered those five then you can move
on to the next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
sprint burn down
so the sprint burn down is the chart we
use when you're tracking usually it's in
scrum is where that usually comes from
the scrum
setup
but it's a chart of the work to be
completed and what's still going on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness
time coverage defect resolution time
explain bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique which models the
end-to-end business process step
the four essential elements of bpmn are
flow objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations
swim lanes pool or lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews
during how many times i've been on the
phone calling competition
um potential clients to ask questions
uh so
one of the elicitation techniques is to
ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions it can a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis
focus group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important i just kind of
highlight a few of them that i tend to
get stuck in
observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis
and you're bringing people into a
workshop and do observations in the
workshop and working specifically with
these people they turn into potential
business growth
i tell you what if you're a shareholder
and someone's doing a business analysis
and they turn around
and generate a 30 000 sell for your
company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
survey questionnaire surveys my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
list of documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document
project vision document
use cases
system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability matrix
functional requirement document
use case specifications document
gaap analyst document
describe how you would approach a
project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams
tracking the project documenting the
progress
and really when you
start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here so important with the shareholders
if you i mean it's great if you can
identify your project goal and that's
probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal
you might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams that is
such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case
different steps are used to complete the
goals of a use cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors
this does not lead to achieving the
required goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following points should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis
display your analysis skills think
critically
and i'm going to throw in here the term
from big data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph
a very simple set of notes
um and you need to think critically you
need to really make it
what is it that the shareholders want
that's going to make them understand why
this is important to the business and
what does the business get out of it
what is kanban kanban helps agile teams
in visually managing work through
processes it works as a scheduling
system in agile just in time production
the kanban methodology is all about
real-time communication of capacity and
full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you got to be very careful about
uh
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micro
management setup where you want to you
want to watch out for that but you also
need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow as the to do in progress and
done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
state the key differences between brd
and srs
brd business requirements documents is a
high-level functional specification of
software
brd is a formal document to describe the
requirement provided by the client
business analysts create this post
through interaction with the clients
srs
system requirement specification is a
high level functional and technical
specification of software
srs describes the software's functions
and non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas srs is
created by the systems architects
what is pareto analysis the pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most
relevant and the least decision
concerning the overall goal
it is also known as the 80 20 rule
as per this rule 82 percent of the
project's benefit arises from twenty
percent of the work
vice versa eighty percent of the case
problem can be due to twenty percent of
the causes
differentiate between the v model and
the fish model
we talk about the v model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a v shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step
v model consumes less time and costs
the fish model is similar to the v model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is comparatively very costly
and time-consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage for
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each region's country that made the
highest revenue create a pivot table by
dragging the region and country onto
rows place the total revenue column
under values
right click on the country value select
the filter options and choose top 10
choose top one as shown above and click
on ok
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the cells data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand
you need to use an advanced filter
option in microsoft excel to solve this
problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select advanced filter option choose
copy to another location
give your criteria range and the copy to
location click on ok
here's the final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest amount profit
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and the country into rows place
the profit column under values right
click on any country value select the
filter option and choose top ten choose
bottom one and click on ok
let's create a filled map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america using tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under kalur in the filters
card drag the region column and select
north america
in the filters card drag the item type
column and select beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america
who knew
using tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters and the total profit
onto calor
the above graph depicts the cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest
and really when we're talking about
tools like tabloo
or if you're targeting companies working
in r
or you're targeting companies working in
python
you should be able to quickly do these
kind of displays in any of those
packages that you're focused on
tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also
very robust and easy to use and uses
less programming on the back end
so just a quick side note on there
really just leads up if you if this does
not look right to you you're not able to
get through some of these things make
sure you are if that's what you're
targeting in a company for an interview
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on business analyst full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comments section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here